How would you summarize why men are in
crisis now?
I think it's because it in a deep level,
the West has lost faith in the idea of
masculinity.
Now that's no different than the death
of God.
It's the same thing and so and need chip
knew what the consequences of that would
be.
I mean that's most of what he wrote
about and so you'd say,
well,
the divine symbol of masculinity has
been obliterated.
Well,
so then what do you expect?
What's going to happen?
It's going to.
That means masculinity is going to
become weak,
and especially if the symbol is also
denigrated,
right?
Which it definitely is.
So what that means is that the ideal
that man could aspire to is denigrated,
and while then with your ideal in
tatters,
you're weak.
That's,
that's definitional.
So I think the reason that men have been
responding positively to my,
my thinking,
let's say,
is that I don't buy any of that.
I like the masculine spirit.
It's necessary and it's not
fundamentally
carnage and pillaging.
It's not fundamentally rape culture.
No,
it's not fundamentally world destroying
and all of those things have been.
All of those aspersions have been cast
upon it.
That's partly the guilt of Western
Society for technological progress even,
and those are reasonable challenges to
be set before men,
but they're not reasonable accusations
to swallow without criticism.
What is a masculinity we can aspire to?
Well,
it's a responsibility fundamentally and
and it's,
it's,
it's to,
to put it symbolically is that your
responsibility is to incarnate the
spirit of the logos.
That's your responsibility.
That's your role in life,
and that is independent to some degree
in whether or not you accept the idea of
a transcendent eternal reality.
Now I'm not making a case for that or
against that I,
those things are beyond human
understanding,
but we know what happens if people act
poorly.
If men act badly,
we know what happens.
We know that the world turns into
something that's so close to hell,
but the difference is trivial.
We know that that's the story of the
20th century,
so we should learn that lesson and what
that lesson is is pick up the world on
your shoulders and walk forward,
pick up the world with all of its
trouble,
with all of it's suffering with all of
its evil and move forward with it and in
bearing that burden learned that you
were that sort of creature that can bear
that burden and therefore deserving of
respect.
That's,
that's the,
that's identification with the logos and
that's.
I don't,
I've never encountered an idea that's
better than that because it's not.
It's so not naive.
It's the opposite of naive.
It's like there's terrible evil and
there's terrible suffering.
It's a bottomless,
but the human spirit is capable of
voluntarily taking that on as a
challenge.
Well,
it's worth a try.
Yes,
exactly.
That's,
that's,
that's the positive.
Meaning.
That's the positive meaning.
That's the world affirming,
meaning you know,
and that that's that self esteem,
let's say,
you know,
which is very poorly characterized.
It's very shallowly characterized
because it usually doesn't involve any
sense of responsibility,
but you know,
it's obvious if you.
It's obvious in some ways if you look at
the people that other people
spontaneously respect,
unless they've become unbelievably
cynical,
it's the people who adopt responsibility
and deal with it competently,
so it's not a mystery that that would be
what you could aspire to.
Now it it gets undermined if you feel
that that force of responsibility is the
raping and pillaging patriarchal culture
that's despoiling the natural
environment and that's equivalent to a
cancer.
Well,
you know,
no,
I don't buy that.